uh we are now joined by uh magnus
carlsen after
a loss in that last game what's your
reaction to that magnus
uh it was really really unnecessary i
feel
um i mean
i couldn't at some point um
at some point i was
you know i was i was trying trying to
win a bit and
i couldn't couldn't find the the right
time to um
to sort of pull yeah pull the handbrake
and then
uh in the end i just splendored
knight g5 k7
96 pack because otherwise i would be at
least fine
um but after that after i bonded that
i sort of collapsed completely so that
was um
yeah it feels extremely unnecessary to
end
end the day that way and magnus how will
how do you feel about today uh you've
got a couple of wins ending on a
difficult defeat uh would it set you up
nicely for tomorrow
i have to say this really really pisses
me off the
the last the last game um there was just
uh i mean first of all i i played really
really poorly when i exchanged queens
and then
he went for this insane c4 thing we
should
never ever give him anything um instead
of just going h5 and
h4 h5 and being better i have no idea
what he was thinking there um and then
yeah i mean i i just made a number of
four
decisions after that and then he
converted he converted well but
this is really um the
to me at least felt like the worst kind
of self-inflicted
wound minus yesterday you didn't
describe your chest in the kindest word
now if you look
at today overall because there's also
two great wins here
what words will you use to describe if
you're able to sort of look away from
that last game
all right still over i mean i kind of
just
look away from from one game because you
play
five games on one day and like
you you cannot just exclude one game and
also the blender i've made against the
gear was
terrible um so overall still
a long way to to go but yeah
whatever i'll uh try and
try and get better tomorrow but this
yeah this is upsetting yeah i can
understand you are
in seventh place now in the preliminary
so
um are you how are you feeling before
that last day what will be the tactics
to secure
a place in the knockout i don't know
all right magnus thank you for joining
us we wish you the best of luck tomorrow